people in england who test positive for
kova 19 will no longer have to
self-isolate starting thursday prime
minister boris johnson made the
announcement monday as he scrapped the
last remaining kova 19 domestic
restrictions for england so let us learn
to live with this virus
and continue protecting ourselves and
others without restricting our freedoms
the government says it still plans to
keep some contingency measures in place
should another variant surface johnson
says while he does not want people
throwing caution to the wind with a high
vaccination rate the government is
pushing a mandate of personal
responsibility instead of proof of
vaccination testing is also changing as
of april only older people and the
immunocompromised will be able to access
free lab pcr tests rapid tests will also
only be available at a price britain's
opposition leader feels the measures
leave the country vulnerable the prime
minister promised to present a plan for
living with kobed
but all we've got today is yet more
chaos and disarray
thousands of kilometers away tears of
joy were flowing in australia as it
fully reopened its borders to vaccinated
tourists reuniting families and friends
for lauren potter from the u.s it was a
long time coming so i haven't seen my
dad in four years so it was great to hug
him and
all the little welcome presents just
make me feel at home it's really special
new zealand will also reopen its borders
to some vaccinated travelers next month
and prime minister jacinda ardern
signaled monday the lifting of vaccine
mandates and other measures once the
omicron peak has passed and in israel
visitors will be able to enter as long
as they get two pcr tests regardless of
their vaccination status a coming change
as countries move out of their omicron
waves and tried to shift to an endemic
state of living with the virus
sean previl global news